[Music]
yeah that's started playing the guitar
when I was about six years old but prior
to that I had been playing the ukulele
for about a year or two it was a program
a live show in Pittsburgh called
Pittsburgh on parade which featured
young young talent so the act was really
simple I would go out and sing a song
with my ukulele take the ink related
back handed to my dad my brother and
cousin join me and the three of us would
go back onstage and we do a tap dance
and we were called the rhythm boys that
led to my playing the guitar which was a
little more you know a better sounding
instrument for my for my songs when I
went to Carnegie Mellon I got daily
classes that changed my life I thought
because I do all that stuff
I knew the chords I knew the harmony I
knew the theory I didn't know what
counterpoint was are giving us some of
the little technical things but getting
the theory and getting the education of
how it all comes together was the most
important thing and I think that that
led me to to become a better teacher and
I think music education is important I
always have it had a strong desire to
pass a lot like love for the guitar to
other people basically I'm really
devoted to jazz and so I try to make all
my students jazz players I help my
legacy is that remember me as a good
guitar player and somebody had shared
music I've always been a little bit of a
musician and a little bit of a performer
you know and I think that's that's been
part of my success because I'm always
interested in pleasing the crowd
that's my legacy
[Music]
you